what is the difference between men who
can endure almost anything in order to
achieve success
and Men
who just easily give up when times are
tough
mental toughness
ask yourself
how tough are you really
how about tasting yourself
answer all the following questions
truthfully
from one to ten one being terrible and
ten being perfect
question number one am I able to control
my thoughts easily
question two how well do I control my
emotions
how do I handle rejection
how quickly do I give up on things that
I struggle with
how quickly do I recognize when my
behavior is not in line with my values
is my self-worth based on truth
how do I react to emotional or physical
pain
how well do I take care of my health
how do I handle self-doubt when I
experience it
how quickly do I stand up again and try
again after I failed now there are more
questions that we can ask but this
should be enough to give you an idea of
where you currently are when it comes to
mental toughness
and even if you think that you're good
there's always room to improve
Butler Russell said concentration and
mental toughness are the margins of
victory
so let me give you five things that will
help you to improve your mental
toughness and if you watch the video all
the way to the end I've got a Bonus tip
for you that you don't want to miss
let's start with number one
live in truth
you cannot improve yourself if you are
not brutally honest with yourself it's
impossible
so stop all the excuses stop blaming
other people or things
and take responsibility for yourself
brutal honesty will help you to improve
your emotional stability perspective
Focus attitude and contentment
people who lie to themselves or want to
live in a make-up world that's not true
are usually more unstable emotionally
unstable especially when reality hits
them in the face
but when you are truthful to yourself
and with everything around you if you
live in truth you will have the right
perspective to make good decisions Under
Pressure because you will look at things
more objectively and not subjectively
Honesty will help you to focus on the
right things the things that actually
matter in your life to bring it closer
to your goals because when you live in
truth it is so much easier to identify
the lies you know those lies that your
own doubts bring you or your emotions
that's fickle that always change listen
carefully you need to train your mind to
be a lot stronger than your emotions or
else you will always fail the truth
shall set you free the Bible says that
for good reason
to truth think about truth speak truth
and live truth
control your thoughts
you know you can't always control what
thought just pops into your head
but what you can control is whether
you're gonna continue with that thought
or we're gonna push that thought out of
your mind you need to learn to take
every thought captive control it
if you don't it's going to control you
Napoleon Hill said if you fail to
control your mind you may be sure you
will control nothing else
guard your thoughts
I just said that sometimes you can't
really control if a thought just pops
into your head right but sometimes you
can because you allow yourself to go to
certain places listen to certain people
or social media and that influences the
way you think about things you need to
control it from the people around you
from TV movies music or social media all
these things these noises around you
they are powerful and if you don't
control it
is going to change and influence the way
you think about everything even
unconsciously changing you listen
carefully
to the following words what consumes
your mind controls your life
in other words as a man thinks so he is
it's a guy in South Africa called Angus
bacham that said that and it is so true
let's take the example of music I mean
everybody loves music right
but the music that's available today is
so different from long ago I mean you
could listen to music from the old days
because it tells a story today it says
the same thing 10 times over and over
again and you can't even listen to the
words because it makes you cringe
what are you allowing into your mind
think about this seriously the other day
I was on the train and it was this guy
walking past and he's just walking in
his own world listening to headphones
and he's just swearing a lot in the
words
he was saying man he was
oblivious to the world around him he's
just in his own head with those swear
words living it
I felt so sad for him to be honest
let me ask you again what are you
allowing into your mind is it making you
better or is it making you worse you
need to stop everything that is
influencing you negatively
feed your mind with good you need to
focus on those things that makes you a
better man that builds you up makes you
mentally tough start to follow good role
models on social media to learn how they
think
read books that build your mind into a
Powerhouse watch movies or series that
make you better don't waste time on
nonsense and listen to music that brings
truth and light into your life and build
relationships with the right kind of
people
why because iron sharpens iron
leave your past
and focus on your future
too many people are controlled by their
difficult past their mistakes their
failures and bad experiences
if you keep thinking about the past
then that is where you will stay and it
will prevent you from moving forward C.S
Lewis said you can't go back and change
the beginning but you can start where
you are and change the ending
I know a lot of people say you have to
let go of the past but they don't tell
you the truth of the past because you
can't just ignore it because that won't
allow you to move on
you need to deal with it once and for
all before you can move on you need to
deal with it to build your mental
toughness to overcome those hardships
the right way forgive those that hurt
you because if you don't it's like
carrying poison with you all the time
you're just hurting yourself
and this is important forgive yourself
look we are not perfect human beings we
make mistakes why because that's just
the way we are we have a sinful nature
in us and we make mistakes but
when you make a mistake you need to make
it right
that's what a real man will do you stand
up you don't just lay down there after
you've failed and mow a poor little me
or I'm not good enough and oh this
happened and that happened no
don't victimize yourself stand up
learn from your mistakes why because
then you'll be stronger and then you
move forward with more power
all right guys I promised you the bonus
tip and this bonus tip
it is extremely important because it is
more powerful than all the other five
tips combined it enabled me to see
things as they are and it gives me the
strength to overcome my own weaknesses
so what is it
it is God's spirit Within Me
before you leave if you're unbeliever
hear me out if you are a true reborn
Christian you know what I'm talking
about because you can testify to this if
you're a new believer or unbeliever then
you would want to know what I'm talking
about true reborn Christians not fake
Christians true reborn Christians
are spiritually reborn they are New
Creations spiritually alive
because they have God's spirit within
them and that gives them the strength to
overcome any obstacle
and millions of Christians true reborn
Christians including myself can testify
to this the Bible says in 2 Timothy 1
verse 7 for God gave us a spirit not of
fear but of power and love and
self-control
many people who don't know what a true
Christian is they think that
Christianity is just this religion where
you go to church you obey certain rules
and you try to be a good person it's
just part of the tradition
oh oh no it is so much more than that
what you are talking about is just a
dead religion and it has no strength yes
there are many people who are fake
Christians it is just a dead religion
with no power if you don't have a true
relationship with God almighty
where he opened up your spiritual eyes
where you have a true relationship with
him that is God that gives you new
spiritual life through his spirit
that he puts within you John 4 24 says
God is Spirit
and those who worship Him must Worship
in spirit and Truth
you know I didn't understand this before
I became a Christian well you can't
understand it right because you can only
worship God in spirit and in truth but
you can't know the truth if you don't
know the spirit because God is Spirit
right so the only way to connect with
him is through the spirit and there is
only God that can give you his spirit so
that happened to me after I lost my
second brother I became a reborn
Christian and God spoke to me deep
within my inner man and this is not me
being weird here guys this is just me
being truthful to you talking about the
truth of life itself
from that day when I became a reborn
Christian God gave me his spirit and I
started to see things through my
spiritual eyes the truth of everything
is like the sun you know you believe
that the sun exists right but through
the sun you see everything else clearly
and it's the same way of God you believe
he exists that he is true but through
him after you've accepted him as Lord
and Savior you see everything for what
it is even your own true life and it
gives you the power
this is that kind of power where you
have peace in all situations even in the
worst conditions of this life I mean
there's life it throws you a lot of ups
and downs right
but I still have joy and peace even in
the worst of conditions and that's
because of God's spirit Within Me
from that day
when I truly became a reborn Christian
when I received the spirit
I changed I received power
and every day since then
I've improved it's God that worked that
change within me my mental toughness
just increased day after day of the day
and it's still increasing I mean there's
almost nothing that can just break me
down now
from my own flesh yes but through God's
spirit in me no
I want to invite you if you want to know
more what I'm talking about and he's not
crazy this is just me being honest with
you guys because I care about you
if you want to know more I mean what can
you lose
watch these videos here from my other
channel
before you go always remember this and
take it seriously
life is short
so don't waste yours just guys